Chris Gore, Founder/Owner of FilmThreat/Author/Filmmaker:
Why are 99 percent of movies garbage, well
you know sometimes they’re garbage movies
are made on purpose.
Film Courage: Here’s a thought, have movies
lost their cool because television has become
so good?
So if you think back to growing up TV was
was more restricted and everything cool happened
in movies like Kramer Versus Kramer.
Oooh…there were some scenes that I wasn't
supposed to see but I saw them anyway right?
Now you can see it all on TV.
Chris: Yes I do think that television has
succeeded so well when it comes to long-form
storytelling.
I do think that there is a bit of abuse in
that where I've seen series that were six
episodes/six hours that would have made a
really good two-hour movie.
But I think that there's an appetite for the
serialized long-form storytelling and we've
become used to that.
We've become used to the binge watching so
going to the theater to see a story that's
going to wrap itself up in hopefully two hours
maybe is not as satisfying and even when you
look at the Star Wars films or the Marvel
movies, it really is just every Marvel movie
is a continuation of the last Marvel movie
in some form because we know there's going
to be easter eggs.
We know there's going to be cameos from characters.
So Marvel movies in a sense have become not
only its own genre but sort of a form of long-form
storytelling with the Disney plus series the
those kind of filling in the blanks between
movies.
But I think that television is great.
I mean television is where no clothes in movies
has migrated.
There's hardly people without clothing in
films anymore.
I mean you're going sacrifice something at
the box office if you choose to include grown
up themes in your feature film being released
to theaters, if there's birthday suits in
it that has migrated onto television.
you know it's Mr. Skin [AuthorJim McBride]
who was recently on the Film Threat podcast
told me it's a golden age of birthday suits
in television, not so much at the movies.
There aren't like the genre of teen whoopie
comedy kind of doesn't even exist.
People forget that the original Porky's film
[1981] such as it was it does feature people
without clothing but also there's an underlying
message of anti-semitism woven within that
film that of course no one remembers except
for me, I remember this.
I don't know why I remember weird facts but
maybe this is also why television, part of
the reason that television in a way is more
popular than than films I don't know if anyone's
ever done this study I would love to see because
I think box office isn't a relevant metric
by which to look at.
It's something the industry uses as a piece
of marketing I don't like that box office
is so important.
It tends to be to Hollywood because it's again
a piece of marketing.
My mother who doesn't pay attention to the
industry whatsoever she knows what the number
one movie at the box office is because it's
used in the marketing of movies right.
But that's not an important number because
that number is irrelevant because due to inflation
if adjusted to inflation and you can look
this up Gone With The Wind [1939] is in the
top films not whatever the purported top films
are right.
Because we're not privy to a lot of the data
from these streaming services.
We really don't know what is incredibly popular
but they wouldn't be making so many of these
series if they weren't at least getting numbers
that got the eyeballs they needed to be somewhat
profitable but because we as the general public
are not privy to those numbers, other than
the people who have access to that data, we're
not able to learn the lessons from that.
There are lessons to be learned about the
failure of something like Terminator: Dark
Fate [2019].
Right there's a lesson to be learned.
I don't think Hollywood's quite learned the
lesson yet.
That's kind of how we learn right?
You see what resonates with an audience and
box office is one barometer of that adjusted
to inflation I think is the better way to
report those numbers.
Film Courage: Do you have more hope for the
future of television or film?
Chris: I certainly have hope for the future
of television.
There are I think that statistically speaking
if I watch something on television and I vet
that choice the idea that I'll have a good
experience with a show based on recommendations
(friend recommendations) tends to hit more
often than not with the movies, not so much
with the movies.
It's probably 50/50 or less.
There will be a decent experience if I know
what I'm getting into I am a person that does
enjoy a good bad film.
Film Courage: Why?
Chris: Good/bad films are just I mean look
there's a certain kind of television that
is made for stoners right.
I think a show like Archer (that’s the animated
show) Archer that's like stoner tv.
I mean most of the Adult Swim shows are for
stoners right?
They're sort of a good/bad.
I mean like Tim & Eric [Tim Heidecker and
Eric Wareheim] their show.
It's kind of based on that and there are films
I tend to like but I know that they're bad
Troma movies by Lloyd Kaufman one of the longest
existing independent film studios is Troma
Studios.
What you're getting into you also should be
aware that James Gunn from The Suicide Squad
and The Guardians Of The Galaxy franchise,
he began his career at Troma Studios, he wrote
Tromeo and Juliet [1996] so I know it's going
to be bad, it's not like something that's
going to change my life but I will laugh and
I don't have to be fully engaged in it except
for maybe the scenes where there's lots of
gore or violence which you can always count
on in a Troma movie but that's the place where
a lot of people cut their teeth is in the
exploitation genre.
Everyone from James Gunn, Francis Ford Coppola,
Ron Howard who famously worked for Roger Corman,
it's a place you can play and it's okay to
fail and to learn the basics.
I think it's just as important to watch a
bad film and take the lessons from it as it
is to watch a good film.
So why are 99 percent of movies garbage well
sometimes garbage movies are made on purpose.
There's a big business in that.
Just ask Lloyd Kaufman or Charlie Band Full
Moon Entertainment famously done most famously
known for the Puppet Master series (love the
Puppet Master films) they're dumb fun.
I think it's kind of like just knowing what
you you know you can't eat steak for dinner
at every meal.
Sometimes fast food or quick meals are going
to work their way in and that's what I consider
a bad movie.
I just want to know I'm getting one, unlike
Terminator: Dark Fate where I go into every
movie hopeful going to every movie it's going
to be awesome and it's not.
Film Courage: When an artist wins a Razzie,
how much of it do you think was actually planned
or none of it?
I mean does anyone really want to win?
Chris: I don't know that anyone ever wants
to win a Razzie [a Golden Raspberry Award].
I mean Showgirls [1995] won a Razzie.
I mean that film actually we look at now there's
so much more going on in that film Showgirls.
There are bad movies that age differently.
Maybe they were ahead of its time, they're
ahead of their time like a film like the original
Blade Runner [1982] or a film like Showgirls
that there was much more going on beneath
the surface.
I mean the trans community in particular has
embraced the movie Showgirls as just having
much deeper meaning.
There's a documentary that discusses this
that I highly recommend that you check out
called you You Don’t Nomi [2020].
Check out that documentary.
That's a whole deep dive analysis of Showgirls,
a sort of re-examination of that.
Additionally, like why there's a whole fandom
around Showgirls which I find fascinating
great documentary that breaks that apart and
looks at it but we just don't know what's
going to age well with time.
What's going to defy, what will be a cult
classic which no filmmaker wants to win a
Razzie or have a film that's called a “cult
classic,” because both of those things imply
that you failed and I don't think I've ever
met a filmmaker that tried to make a bad movie.
Although I will say this, John Waters has
a great quote about that.
John Waters said if you try to make a bad
film you can't fail.
Question For The Viewers:
What is your favorite bad movie?